oh yeah he just read the manual how to
fly a plane he was just sitting as a
co-pilot and they just took took off
like yeah Kim Jong-un now knows how to
fly a plane oh my God what can't he do
yeah what can he do lose weight
[Music]
good news everybody we got some good
news from North Korea for a change good
news from Ryan correction I don't know
if I believe Ryan no don't I don't have
any this is my favorite country in the
world yeah there's no twists or due for
some good news I think Kim Jong-un just
declared a formal order that all North
Koreans must now stop committing suicide
or else that's cool he took a stand or
else I'll kill you kill your whole
family yeah he really he really just
declared a ban on suicide because too
many people are killed themselves we got
some stats and he doesn't like that you
know what's crazy it's stats are so hard
to come by because they refuse to
release them but the little tidbits that
they do get are really disturbing really
full families are killing themselves not
just one dude like households are
killing themselves well the quality of
life is just so so great right
it's so great
what's happening over there why are they
so that yeah I thought he invented the
burrito and then everyone was happy yeah
yeah
the wheat wrap uh yeah so now uh killing
yourself is you're you're penalized as
an it's an act of treason now
so that does that make people go oh I
better not oh [__] we better not do it
yeah we should we don't want to be
treasonous yeah so I know it sounds
really silly but what happens is that uh
if you kill yourself
you can also uh get in trouble I think
your own family you're surviving oh
three generations right yeah and also it
says here that the officials who are
like in charge of your District or
something could also be in trouble like
we don't give a [__] about the officials
that's what's gonna kind of motivate
them to sort of do better I don't know
or or is this gonna cause more families
to commit suicide too many people
getting in trouble all the time like
Bloodlines you know like [__] it we
might as well just kill ourselves now
jeez that's so crazy so it's happening a
lot to the point where you had to make
it Ryan this is a hot this is kind of a
question for you do you think Kim
Jong-un is like a pretty good leader
how is that a question what do you think
I'm gonna say do you think he's like uh
like objectively speaking like take
politics out of it do you think
I don't even got two sides over there
yeah do you think he's like
how about this I think he's I think he's
doing his best with God
is not neutral enough yeah you're a PR
guy yeah I don't see the difference
between like a king during medieval
times and the Kim family it's a dynasty
it's like he's you know but they're just
wearing communist outfits but it feels
like he's a king they have cooler
haircuts too I think the difference is
in the medieval times if you hear like
word from far away lands you're like oh
okay it's just this shitty over there I
think over here they're like wait none
of the world lives like this and I think
that's what probably makes them go that
must be wild can you imagine growing up
in like a village out there and then
like you get a smartphone one day and
you see like all that [__] like what the
[__]
I mean they have it's probably blocked
but they change the SIM card and then
they go what the [__] what do you think
about this I think it's [__]
absolutely insane people Count Their
Blessings who live in the United States
yeah for real because they they
brainwash them and think that they're
demigods you know so you got to worship
the statue you know when you Walks Like
You Gotta cry there's only a certain
amount of haircuts men's can get I mean
it's it's crazy it's like illegal to
take the picture off from your home yeah
there's just so many coat like his yeah
because that's the coolest code
the craziest thing to think about is
somebody who's born in North Korea yeah
and died in North Korea and never knew
anything else did you know a lot of um
defectors go back like the percentage is
like they can't deal with more people go
back to North Korea than stay outside
they say life is harder even though
they're like eating a lot but no friends
well they also get treated they also get
treated they're discriminated and yeah
right
they're not really like welcomed in the
same way that you would expect yeah I
wonder what happened and they go back
they probably get killed and their
family oh you came back come here buddy
why do you look so healthy huh
I wonder if it's which which direction
you think it's easier to go right from
South Korea to North Korea Escape or
return what's he oh oh dude probably
escaping you think escaping is easier oh
returning back to Oh you mean like just
living or just like what's what's easier
to do yeah for like the actual Act of
leaving or entering a prison break or a
prison break in yeah I said going back
yeah yeah oh it's harder what's your
name that escaped from North is it Kim
Park oh the yeah you want to meet Park
yeah her story is crazy yeah her story
is wild why do you think going back is
easier because I I think like they just
go to the line the front line be like
hey I'm a Defector I'm a Defector and it
just freaking cross then then planning
the Escape like okay they got these
fence off we got to try to make it
through these Barbed wires this is the
patrol of this area you have to know
somebody on the outside to even filter
you through the fact that anybody
escapes is crazy yeah that's super crazy
isn't it like a thing too that when
someone escapes they kind of get treated
with distrust as if like you're really
just you're a mole yeah yeah they go
like yeah we sure you escaped you know
they send you up here to yeah they just
don't want you in any kind of like
important job or anything like worth
having because they're just like okay
you know that's pretty [__] up they do
a lot of uh North Korean Defector
interviews on I think it's called Asian
boss it's like a it's a YouTube channel
but like they record a lot in Asia and
man I just went down this rabbit hole
because there's like
of hundreds of defectors like in South
Korea right from different levels of
government different levels of class out
there and then their stories are just so
different and I mean it'll probably be
like here like if if a wealthy person in
America ran away versus like someone you
know that's poor or like someone that's
from the military that they have
different stories yeah so I was like
that was that's pretty interesting but
one thing this um former military guy
said is that they do send spies over
purposely to talk big about how strong
the North Korean military is be careful
and they're just bragging
they're trained to like tell a story and
that in to like not make it seem like
it's fake yeah but then like it's kind
of like little by little and I was like
damn that's a that's an interesting
tactic subin how do we tell the
difference between a North and South
Korean the way the way it physically
yeah
the way they look this one's really
hungry one's like it has anything they
look different yeah they're mad skinny
yeah
would you say they're mannerism since
they were raising like in that type of
type of culture for so long like the way
they they speak yeah the way they speak
you know how yeah probably South Korea
is more like Western culture influence
compared to like up there the way they
say speak talk yeah Koreans you know
they're more relay back when they talk
yeah
of course
like a military speech or something
everyone's so fast whoa I don't even
know what they're saying to be honest
really yeah I'm Korean too I don't know
what they're saying
there it is it's quick it's fast so they
just sound like they're communist just
the way they're yeah well they sound
like they're in the 19 something still
oh
Korean has slangs now and more you know
like you said westernized it's more
different
still stuck back there no drip in the
language huh no drip they got no swag
dude they got no North Korean swag clean
cut that's true because they just still
have accordion bands and stuff you ever
see those 50 dudes playing accordion and
[__] looks like Mata Russia dude they
watch TV on the USB drive
for real yeah what kind of shows they
got on there [__] I don't know Breaking
Bad you think they're watching Breaking
Bad yeah right what if it's like every
American show but with like Kim jong's
like [__] face all the main
characters [__] Rambo oh funny
they just remake American films where
he's the heroes
are pretty good
cube is kind of tight did you see that
little propaganda these all the
adventures when they had Kim like oh
yeah he just read the manual how to fly
a plane he was just sitting as a
co-pilot and they just took took off
like yeah Kim Jong-un now knows how to
fly a plane oh my God what can't he do
yeah what can he do lose weight
burn slam don't show them his videos
foreign